the jurogan experience
i think you said it also very a very
good point which is
who has the time
that's a big one i mean because it does
take me three times longer to read to
read a news article yeah because i got a
vet
i don't have to i could be like a lot of
other probably most people but they're
counting on it if i if i read this and
something doesn't vibe with me i sit
there and i go look up and i do research
i mean we don't all have a jamie right
next to us
you know
checking everything that we say and
calling this out if i was wrong it's
like the idea that forever for this
whole time i thought that jay-z said
that quote right and then you guys then
i was like well i don't know maybe i'm
wrong but
you know but it's like but we don't have
most people don't take that time
like if somebody else would have
corrected me on the on this on the bus
and i don't know if anybody would have
taken the time to google that and make
sure well that's not even important
right that's not even important right
now
have to look up and try to figure out
like why are we in afghanistan or why is
this happening or why is that important
or why is this law being passed or
what's
you know what's the real motivation
behind this drug being pushed like what
what the [ __ ] is going on with that guy
who's
and there's so much of that in this
world that it's
you could lose yourself like if you
didn't have a job and your entire day
was sifting through the news and trying
to find truthful narratives versus
propaganda you would lose your [ __ ]
mind how much did you think is that
because how much you think right now the
exaggeration of it is because of that
because that people have a chance to now
consume
so much
of this information i think that you
know locking people in their house when
they just have access to the internet
i think i thought about it this way when
i remember we were in um
at the beginnings of our first
quarantined kind of lockdown thing and i
was like but i still had
netflix
and i still had face time
and i still had i mean it didn't i was
like this is fine like i really it
wasn't that
bad i wasn't going crazy but i was like
imagine if this happened in 1985 right
right i mean and you had to wait till
the next morning to get a newspaper well
maybe the newspaper wouldn't be printed
because nobody worked in the newspaper
and imagine if the newspaper was as full
as [ __ ] as cnn is
and then you gotta you're lost you
really don't know what's true or what's
what's lies what's propagating yeah you
have that one thing yeah i was thinking
like man how
how
difficult would it have been how much
more isolated would it have been
if we just can only get the information
twice a day once a day
and we have one channel
to two or three channels local news or
whatever it was you know we didn't even
have that you know whatever well there
was so much propaganda back then that
just slipped through the cracks it took
forever before
something
came hit the light of day right
right where something was uh obvious
like especially like government [ __ ]
like golf alpha tonkat incident that led
us into vietnam i mean there's a bunch
of those yeah
instances there's a lot of gatekeepers
back there yeah oh my god and there was
agreements with the news the news had
agreements with politicians and
and government agencies and they you
know they followed the narrative
and i just yeah so i think that maybe us
now with access to all this information
and all this content and all this data
and all these people all these voices of
somebody that used to do 10 minutes of
twitter now doing four hours of twitter
and just sitting there and getting in
these loop rabbit holes i mean it's got
to be damaging like you gotta like we
said a lot of it is junk food i treated
a lot of it like junk food like you know
i love a potato chip every once in a
while but if i ate it for eight hours a
day i think it would probably be pretty
unhealthy
and so it's like consuming this kind of
garbage yeah there's a guy named alan
lavinovic and he's uh he's
he's looked at it
in the the same way you look at
processed food that's how he described
it he's like you you can't eat all
processed food and you can't eat all
processed information
and that's what it is it's like this
social media version of information is
just processed information right and
you're getting it and these weird sort
of bursts and it's all boiled down with
preservatives on it and not filled with
nonsense it has an agenda
and it's like you know i think that
there's a monetization of of human
suffering i think is difficult you know
anytime you have that opportunity to
where
because it's more interesting and it's
more you want eyeballs onto your content
so you just it's a very simple algorithm
it's just we just need eyeballs so
whatever got people to watch it and
let's get more of that instead of
stuff that's not interesting you know
that's might be just very boring data
you know and so i think you just tend to
lean towards that kind of stuff a little
bit and i think it's tough yeah i just
that's that's the stuff that always
fascinates me a little bit it's just
because i think i think it takes us i
don't think we have a lot of people have
that kind of thing i think that a lot of
people are just like i don't i don't
bother with that i don't i don't take
the time to think no they don't have the
time they don't take the time and that's
oddly enough where podcasts have sort of
come in to fill that void because in
podcasts you can have two intelligent
people just sitting down talking about
stuff in a way like well maybe that's
not true maybe this is true let's find
out let's discuss this and let's figure
out why people are saying this thing
that is clearly untrue and saying it
across like multiple platforms like
what's the motivation behind this like
yeah that's a thing that didn't exist
before because first of all in the past
we didn't think of the news as being
this thing that was lying to us yeah
that's that's a real recent thing and i
think a lot of that was exacerbated
during the time that trump was president
because
the media was so upset that trump had
become the president and so upset that
this what they thought this con man was
now running the entire government that
is time to fight fire with fire and so
they started attacking in the same way
that they felt like he was attacking the
way he would you know call people by a
nickname you know lying ted or you know
[ __ ] lion hillary or crooked hillary
or you know you have all these nicknames
for people
call the news the fake news and like god
we have to fight fire with fire we have
to attack the same way he's attacking
but in doing so they've undermined their
credibility to an almost
irreparable way
right
and that's what's scary right what's
scary is the amount of people that
actually trust the news now is [ __ ]
lower than ever lower than ever and i
think it's because we all believe that
people have an agenda even even with
science people think we're so used to
people having an agenda yeah that people
think that there's an agenda with
everything yeah and there might be i
mean it's not to say that there isn't i
think that that's the balance of it all
to sit there and say i'm again i'm even
victim of what we're talking about right
now which is to say that while i believe
that we probably lean this way
we're not to say that it's a purified
like that there's no such thing that
it's not possible that there's some
puppet master out there that's really
kind of
affecting this this way with that the
third but i'm just saying that at the
end of the day
um not everything has such a mastermind
full type of thought process behind it i
think some of it is a lot more
um
simple i think it's a lot simpler
sometimes it's about just money
sometimes it's about just most of it's
about money yeah that's most of it's
about narratives
narratives that are set up in order to
have people extract money from a system
and that's what's really scary is that
you follow the money and it's right
there and you know many people have
talked for years about getting money out
of politics and getting money out of
to make it so that these people that
make these
huge decisions
that affect policy affect the way we're
allowed to live our lives that there
should be no money being exchanged in
these decisions there should be no
motivation no one should profit from
these things no one
no one
who
wants to be a politician should ever get
exorbitantly wealthy from being a
politician but yet that's the case over
and over and over again
and that's dirty that's that's dirty and
that is what affects these people and
that's what affects the way they behave
and the way they communicate and the
things they talk about and the things
they won't talk about
maybe sometimes is as important watch
the entire episode for free only on
spotify